a Texas teenager who's defying the odds  after a terrible car accident is talking  to us about her remarkable recovery  seventeen-year-old Lacey Johnson was a  passenger when the driver her friend's  mother had a seizure in June Lacey tried  to grab the wheel but couldn't stop the  car from rolling over and she was thrown  from the vehicle the crash left her  paralyzed on one side and doctors told  her family she might not make it but she  was determined to recover they were  amazed they said with my injuries I  supposed to be like that's like over a  year like for a really long time now  Lacey as you saw is up and mobile with  the help of a walker she still has some  hard work ahead members of the community  are helping through a go fund me page  way to go Lacey yeah that a power of the  mind obviously help them that's very  impressive